I can't steer it or stop it and the
under miners escape
[Music]
[Music]
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them all vegetables it all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant moms new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right now they bring supers back into
the sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me i watch the kids no problem to do a
dad they want us to do it I don't know
that way why would they change math math
is Batman hello hey honey everything's
great
he's in excellent health that is freaky
you know it's crazy right to help my
family I gotta leave it to fix the law I
gotta break it you've got to destroy
kids can have that choice thank you
young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen slacker interrupts this
program for an important announced that
it might get weird I'll be there ASAP
[Music]